congresswoman el Han Omar is picking
another fight this time over sports in a
new letter to USA powerlifting
Omar attacks the organization because it
opposes having a biological male compete
against women in a lifting competition
Omar claims ludicrously that biological
males have no advantage over women
that's in defiance of about a million
years or so of evidence to the country
it doesn't matter though Omar's letter
is just the latest case of powerful
people on the left bullying anyone they
can't control you saw the same thing
with the gay marriage debate any
Christian own bakery that doesn't want
to bake a gay wedding cake Chris finds
lawsuit and ruin okay so those are the
new rules so what about Muslim owned
bakeries so the rules apply there too
Steven Carter asked that question a
while back and he found pretty much what
you'd expect lots of Muslim on bakeries
will not bake gay wedding cakes and
we're not complaining about that private
business owners shouldn't be forced to
engage in speech they find immoral but
the left doesn't agree so where's the
letter from congresswoman Omar demanding
that Muslim bakeries who won't bake
these cakes be shut down we're still
looking for that letter and what about
Omar's own mosque by the way does it
perform gay marriages and if it doesn't
as she complained about that as she
didn't a them we called her office say
to find out they haven't replied yet we
suspect we'll be waiting a while for an
answer but we're always open to one
congressman Omar is starting a lot of
fights recently for a newcomer she's in
the center of many news stories today on
Capitol Hill she berated the new envoy
to Venezuela Elliott Abrams accusing him
of being a liar and attacking him over
the iran-contra affair that took place
more than 30 years ago here's part of it
more than 800 civilians including
children as young as two years old were
brutally murdered by u.s. trained troops
you later said that the u.s. policy in
El Salvador
was a fabulous achievement yes sir no do
you think that massacre was a fabulous
achievement that happened under our
watch that is a ridiculous question yes
or no no I think yes I am NOT going to
respond to that kind of personal attack
congressman Omar is herself of course a
refugee to this country she was born in
Mogadishu she spent most of her time at
least her political life attacking this
country as immoral she also supports a
number of policy ideas like the green
New Deal
that don't make mathematical sense she's
also for abolishing ice so there are
things you could criticize about the
congresswoman but you're not allowed to
criticize her a new piece in Politico
argued that now why well not because
what she says is factually true but
because of course of her identity quote
the GOP strategy risks a backlash a
party that has problems with women and
minorities continues to focus its
attacks on women of color and quote not
a women that disagrees with but on women
of color their colors the most important
part to the people of Politico MSNBC
agreed with us of course in a segment
yesterday one of his guests said that it
was quote not a good look for
conservatives to attack congresswoman
Omar because she's a woman
her actual views are irrelevant it's
about her identity